Johnny okay Carter I can stay here all
night so why don't you and I cut the
crap and you tell me what happened on
March 15th and what's in it for Carter
Finley what's in it for you is I don't
send you back to jail
the guy's name is cat branchman
I met him downtown at a club called the
clutching kitten you may have heard of
it it's down on the corner of hang and
fur street cat branchman so what's a guy
like you and a guy named cat
okay I know what you're doing Finley
you're just using what you see am i
posted
I'm not detective I'm telling the truth
we'll see how much truth you tell after
a few weeks to solitary confine
detective you've twisted my arm that's
better
the guy's name wasn't cat branchman it
was a Chinese guy named mr. meow he's
the real gang boss story went he hung
guys from trees and took pictures of
them Finley used to run a club downtown
the front of course called it the paw
and poster Finley ran it with a guy
named Hong indar okay let's try this one
more time
[Music]
friendly
who do you work for coffee mr. coffee
coop coffee coop his name was Baldy tall
man coffee coop now you're just talking
about me Finley I'm gonna give you one
more chance who is in charge his name
was angry man the warehouse is located
in the diploma for being a detective I
want a name Justin Thank You Hank you
don't say hang god damn it do not say
hang hang nope hangman Justin cats
Finley's poster do not say poster or cat
cat poster okay that's it I'm losing my
patience Winslow get this [ __ ] out of
here
[Music]
I'm losing my patience let's try this
one more time get into old for it well
played detective well played indeed hey
caught it you hang in there
[Music]
you